good afternoon and welcome to the cato
institute my name is john samples i'm
vice president here at Cato and
publisher and I would heartily like to
thank you for coming here today for our
viewer's online and being broadcast by
c-span Katie may not know the
unexpectedly The Washington subway
system a metro was closed today so the
people that have joined us here have
made a great effort to hear something
about this book lessons in censorship
how schools and courts subverts students
First Amendment rights which is the
topic of our book forum today
there's another thing that what can be
said about today and we sort of chose
today for this particular book and to
have Katherine Ross here at Cato and the
reason is this is the 260 fifth birthday
of a man named James Madison as it
happens James Madison actually wrote the
First Amendment because he wrote the
first ten amendments that were
introduced into Congress and was a
beyond that more than just the author of
them or the person who wrote them he was
also a strong defender and believed very
heartily in them I should say also I
learned today that in part of that the
part of Madison's birthday being means
that the First Amendment Center a
valuable Institute here in Washington
has designated his birthday National
Freedom of Information Day which is we
are celebrating here today along with
the publication of this book I can't
help however but refer to what I thought
was an interesting and useful comment
from Madison on this very topic the
First Amendment freedoms in First
Amendment and freedom of speech Madison
wrote quote a popular government without
popular and from
with popular information or the means of
inquiring it is but a prologue to a
farce or a tragedy or perhaps both
knowledge will forever govern ignorance
and are people who mean to be their own
governors must earn themselves with the
power which knowledge gives unquote and
we will continue in this faith as we go
down through the history of the United
States that knowledge will govern
ignorant and that the First Amendment is
an essential means as Katharine Ross
just said in the green room to making
the whole system work
Madison interestingly the First
Amendment Center designated him as a
list first person to go in the Freedom
of Information Act Hall of Fame which is
interesting
he's a kind of Hank Aaron I guess of
Freedom of Information that said I hope
we have a person here today our author
who is since down the line will be
candidate for being in the Freedom of
Information Act Hall of Fame
Catherine J Ross the author of lessons
and censorship is a law professor at
George Washington University and during
the current academic year is a visiting
scholar at the Harvard Graduate School
of Education this book lessons in
censorship was named 2015's best book by
concurring opinions First Amendment news
professor Ross specializes in
constitutional law with a particular
emphasis as you might guess in the First
Amendment but also in family law and
legal and policy issues concerning
children she has published and lectured
widely has been interviewed on many
television and radio news shows and has
testified before Congress this is not
however a first appearance in a Cato
forum she was a commentator in January
on a panel we had and she was a
participant in a Cato unbound
conversation which I recommend to
everyone here both in general and in
particular a month or two ago you can
find it at Cato org let me also say that
I am discussing that that if you are
following us today on Twitter please use
the hashtag Kato events on twitter the
hashtag Kato events professor Ross has
also been on the a BAE the American Bar
Association's steering committee on
unmet legal needs of children and
presented a report in 1993 on America's
children at risk to the White House she
has served in many ways at the highest
levels on American Bar Association and
on the editorial boards of the Family
Court's review and family raw law
quarterly she's a distinguished advocate
of the First Amendment and we are happy
to welcome her here today the Cato
Institute and to talk about her book
lessons in censorship Katherine thank
you to all of you for braving the
streets of Washington today and the
sunniest equivalent of a snow day we
have ever seen so I'm gonna begin by
just reading the opening passage from my
book you lose all constitutional rights
once you enter a school building a
school official in Suffolk County in New
York proclaimed in the spring of 2012
you're not allowed to do this she
asserted as she confiscated flyers from
an indignant student who was protesting
her friends five-day suspension layering
censorship upon censorship the episode
had a surreal quality the student whose
plight prompted the pamphlets had been
punished for voicing her opposition to
bullying but in a way the school deemed
inappropriate the seizure was as
clueless as it was surreal because the
First Amendment protects speech rights
of public school students in grades K
through 12 and yet schools all over the
country regularly censor
constitutionally protected speech by
children and judges often let them get
away with it now when I use the word
censorship throughout I'm talking both
about stopping speech before it
and punishing it afterwards schools
silence and punish students who express
their own opinions on every side of
important issues we adults are debating
including national and local politics
the rights of LGBT persons guns abortion
and more they've suspended a
six-year-old who called a classmate a
poopoo head
they stopped one elementary school girl
from praying before eating her own lunch
and another from distributing a homemade
flyer that began hi my name is MB in
which she shared her personal experience
that finding Christ was like finding a
lost dog in the upper grades schools
suspended two boys who were political
t-shirts won praising the Marines I'm
sorry John is this weight mechanical
problem here is this not on and you have
to do it up here okay
we should have practiced I thought this
was all set up okay
oh no well I'm just trying to figure out
can we pause here
I'm so sorry No oh this is awful I have
a beautiful t-shirt to show you okay so
one was praising the Marines and their
gun and another boy was criticizing
president george w bush as a substance
abusing draft-dodging chicken hawk and
schools are increasingly asserting the
authority to punish students for what
they say off campus on their own time a
subject that I'll return to at the end
of my comments the Constitution protects
all of this expression as well as speech
that adults might regard as worthless
but the Constitution protects worthless
as well as worthwhile speech and when we
talk about students we are also often
talking about adolescent humor that's
simply beyond adult comprehension
students are especially likely to get in
trouble for speaking up if somebody
else's parent finds their speech
controversial which really means they
say it's offensive because I disagree
with it but controversial and
disagreeable speech is exactly what the
speech Clause is designed to protect the
powerpoints just disappeared entirely
but okay thank you
students are especially I'm sorry the
the hard I should never use powerpoints
okay the heart of the problem is that
too many principals and school board
members don't know or don't understand
the limits the Constitution places on
their ability to control what students a
while others simply disregard the law
because they don't like it as I worked
on this book almost everybody I talked
to informally said I have a censorship
story either from their own
in school or from their children and
longtime teachers
incredulous li told me that they had no
idea that students had First Amendment
rights and they asked where I come up
with such a creative notion so in
perceiving I have to begin by giving you
a whirlwind tour of First Amendment
doctrine as it applies to students and
then I'll turn to some stories that
capture some of the particular content
per area dilemmas the speech Clause of
the First Amendment is very concise it
says Congress shall make no law
abridging the freedom of speech as
interpreted this means that the
government and anyone acting on behalf
of the government may not silence speech
because of its content or viewpoint
school districts and everyone who works
for them from principals to teachers to
school bus drivers are the government
when we talk about students freedom to
speak my research in my comments today
are limited to public schools because
the First Amendment doesn't apply to
independent schools whether secular or
religious they're not the government the
Supreme Court first took up the issue of
student speech rights in 1943 in one of
the earliest cases in which it actually
upheld the speech rights of any
individual Barnett versus West Virginia
involved elementary school students they
were Jehovah's Witnesses who are at risk
of expulsion and being sent to a
juvenile reformatory because they
refused to say the Pledge of Allegiance
on the ground that it offended their
religion but it was not litigated or
interpreted as a religion case the
consequences today of speaking up and
being punished can also be dire many
students enter the school to Prison
Pipeline as a result of being suspended
expelled or sent to an alternative
school for troubled students after they
engage in protected speech so just like
the Jehovah's Witnesses in 1943 the
consequences are stark
Barnett held that people including young
students could not be forced to say what
was not in their minds a concept we
today called the rule against compelled
speech the Court emphasized the
constitutional limits on the state's
coercive powers whether exercised by
quote village tyrants or by the federal
government and it underscored that the
First Amendment was designed to protect
non conformists of all stripes the court
particularly focused on schools because
the case involved two elementary school
girls it said because schools are
educating the young for citizenship they
must scrupulously protect individual
rights if we're not to strangle the free
mind at its source and to teach youth to
discount important principles of
government as mere platitudes decades
later the court returned to student
speech and began to carve out a special
way of sesang claims that schools had
illegally censored student expression
the first an iconic Supreme Court case
in modern times and here I'm just
listing the cases I don't expect you to
retain all of them but so you don't
wonder when I say the names the monkey
eye the first modern cases tinker versus
Des Moines decided in 1969 at the height
of the Vietnam War and it held that
schools had violated the First Amendment
by suspending students who wore black
armbands to school in order to protest
the war the court took into account all
the things society expects schools to
accomplish especially the importance of
educating young for citizens for
citizenship and it crafted a special
test that gave schools more leeway to
restrain speech than the government has
in the world at large it announced that
schools could not sense your student
expression unless authorities had a
reason to anticipate that the speech
could lead to material disruption of the
school's function or collide with the
rights of others and in short I'll refer
to this as the material disruption test
as the
what became more conservative under
every new chief justice it gradually
carved out exceptions to the material
disruption test in three later cases
these gave schools more and more power
to censor student speech but did not
extinguish student speech rights two of
the exceptions gave the schools
discretion to censor student expression
that's lewd or speech that advocates the
use of illegal substances which you may
recognize as the bong hits for Jesus
case the most important exception stems
from Hazelwood versus Co Meyer a 1988
decision that created a special category
of speech the court labeled
school-sponsored if speech is school
sponsored it is treating its treated as
if the school is speaking and the
student is not even though the speech
originates with the student in such
places as high school papers or literary
magazines but also much further to be
school-sponsored the speech must appear
to bear the schools and premature or in
a justice alito's words to be the
school's own speech so that a reasonable
person would think the school had
approved it this reaches virtually all
expression in student publications
performances extracurricular activities
and more stripping students of their
voices
schools try their best to avoid the
material disruption standard because
it's hard to satisfy they claim that all
cursing is lewd and therefore can be
punished even when students read aloud
from classical literature or mutter to
themselves thinking no one can hear them
some schools have even begun to assert
that what students say in the classroom
and didn't written homework assignments
handed in only to the teacher is
school-sponsored expression though no
one in their right mind could think that
the school had a chance to understand it
and approve it before the students
submitted it or uttered it
this approach severely limits the
viewpoints and our classrooms especially
since teachers in many jurisdictions are
not allowed to disagree with the text
that the school board has selected and
there are many disputes about what
viewpoints should be part of the
official curriculum I won't go into them
but think about disputes over how to
teach such subjects as biology including
evolution and courses on sex ed and even
American history and slavery let me
briefly anticipate some common concerns
about giving students too much freedom
in school recognizing students
constitutional rights will not undermine
education at all there are two concerns
it's going to undermine education or
it's going to put people at risk of
their safety regarding the first concern
education preserving the school's
educational function is the essence of
the material disruption test so
disruption it does not have to be
tolerated as for the second safety
schools may always clamp down on speech
that's illegal outside of school like
true threats a narrow constitutional
standard very hard to satisfy but also
harassment libel and so forth and more
important even speech that's protected
outside of school by the Constitution
that threatens violence or serious
disruption but it does not rise to the
level of a true threat under
constitutional law may always be
silenced by a school before it causes
problems while officials contain the
speaker and investigate whether there is
cause for concern safety comes first so
that's the taxonomy the principal or
other official has to first figure out
what kind of speech this is the students
own that's not food not pro drug or
school sponsored and then within that
taxonomy apply the correct test because
each of these has a slightly slightly
different formulation I understand that
it is really hard for teachers and
principals
in the spur of the moment when they're
worried to try to understand and use a
very complex set of standards but
they're also not adequately prepared to
do that and so I provide a chart in the
book and this is the color version that
can be ordered and placed in a
principal's office like the Heimlich
maneuver poster what do I do now we have
a speech incident okay this is going to
remind me if it's the students own
speech I have to really slow down and I
can't silence it unless there's a threat
of material disruption then I have to
understand something about what best
means this is incomplete legal advice if
it's school-sponsored I need to slow
down
I can censor it but only if I have a
legitimate pedagogical reason and the
fact that someone finds it offensive or
it might be controversial is not a
legitimate reason under the First
Amendment but if its lewd prodrug or
inciting violence or inflammatory in
some way or defamatory I can censor and
punish it at my discretion
so now how does this all work
most of the speech that's at the core of
contemporary debates sexting texting
online speech bullying and racist
expression all falls in the category of
what I call pure student speech it's
governed by the material disruption test
let me begin with creative artists who
commonly get in trouble at school for
fictional and graphic works this is a
poster that a high school senior named
Sarah Bowman who had never been in
trouble she was a good student made
during her lunch hour and posted in the
corridor about 15 minutes later before
any students had seen it they were on
the cafeteria the janitor saw it and got
really upset and took Sarah and the
poster to the principal's office it says
and I'll just capture it
who killed my dog he was my best friend
did you kill my dog did you kill my dog
if you don't tell me who killed my dog
okay
she had taken a course during the summer
that taught her about conceptual art
designed to capture deranged fictional
people and in the principal's office she
explained this principle believed her
but he still said I have to suspend you
for five days subsequently the school
board got involved and the school board
decided that she should be suspended for
81.5 days the rest of her senior year
and that she could not return to school
unless a psychologist examined her and
confirmed that she was mentally fit to
be in school
she soon and the court easily held that
her rights had been violated and she was
able to return to school and complete
her senior year they said once the
principal interviewed her and understood
what was going on there was simply no
reason to anticipate disruption
especially because even if other
students might have been upset had they
seen the poster nobody saw it so there
was no cause for concern at all in a
similar case involving a work of fiction
written fiction an appellate judge
rebuked his fellow appellate panelists
for allowing the school to punish the
writer he said after today students will
have to hide their artwork
they've lost their speech rights if
someone finds their art disturbing they
can be punished
school officials may now he said
subordinate students freedom of
expression to a policy of making high
schools cozy places like daycare centers
where no one may be made to feel
uncomfortable by the knowledge that
others have dark thoughts and all the
art is of hearts and smiley faces so if
you're wondering about the connection
between my book which stops senior year
of high school and some of what's been
going on in today's college campuses
about my students who think that their
comfort level is more
than the expressive rights of their
peers this is part of a connection that
I see though I have not written about it
but it's part of the Cato unbound
discussion that John mentioned earlier
and this brings us to disparaging speech
addressed to groups or individuals many
schools have speech codes those are
simply school rules that prohibit
students from disparaging people based
on categories like race ethnicity sexual
identity and some go much further
talking also about physical appearance
like short people like me or even
something much harder to measure values
students have even been prevented from
expressing views that undermine respect
for a group even though they weren't
actively aiming their comments at the
group or meaning to be disparaging and I
opened by saying that schools censor
both sides of a lot of debates and many
many schools have wrongly prevented
students from forming chapters of the
Gay Straight Alliance or similar groups
or from wearing t-shirts in which
students proclaim their own sexual
identity but here's the flipside in this
story Roman Catholic Daniel Glowacki
resisted a lesson in tolerance on Spirit
Day a national day of recognition for
LGBT teens who committed suicide he told
his teacher
I don't accept gays it's against my
religion and the teacher told him to
leave the room there was no risk of
disruption or only of competing ideas a
federal judge later commented that the
teacher had modeled oppression and
intolerance of student opinion other
students agreed because when Daniel
Glowacki left the room they asked why
doesn't he have free speech the legal
question is whether the Constitution
permits students
I'm sorry permits schools to regulate
hurtful speech addressed to groups or
individuals in school or out of school
and the answer is the Constitution does
not permit that the US is very unusual
Justice Kagan while she was still a law
professor discussant university hate
speech codes and concluded that even an
exceedingly narrow speech code and a
discriminatory harassment cannot survive
constitutional scrutiny in the United
States and Justice Alito - while he was
on the Third Circuit pointed out there's
no right to be protected from hurtful
words free speech principles simply
conflict with efforts to reduce the harm
that disparaging speech can cause so
this is the crowning paradox under our
Constitution a liberal secular democracy
that strives to inculcate tolerance in
our citizens and more importantly
perhaps a culture of mutual respect
rather than simply tolerating each other
must tolerate the expression of in
Tolerance that means that the state
can't use its coercive powers to punish
speech that offends that goal but the
speech Clause doesn't leave educators
without any recourse schools can teach
empathy they can encourage peers to step
up to support each other when someone is
targeted with a hurtful slur or
stereotype and schools can modern model
constructive ways of disagreeing ideally
I would urge that respect for student
speech rights provides a training ground
for exercising rights responsibly for
responding to hurtful speech with more
and better speech as the First Amendment
generally requires and looks for and for
learning how to have substantive
conflicts about real issues without
going too far and cutting off
conversation what I call learning
liberty by living it so I'm going to
close with a third example which is the
growing number of incidents in which
schools reach out claim
they can punish what students have said
off-campus usually online an obstacle
property schools increasingly claim the
power to track and punish what students
say 24/7 some school districts have even
hired retired law enforcement officers
to keep track of their students online
communication from their own computers
from their homes now remember that the
whole rationale for giving schools more
power to restrict speech than the
government has in the world at large is
the special environment and purpose of
the public schools on campus but schools
said they can violate speech that is
fully protected by the Constitution
outside of school if it violates the
school's rules of decorum and they say
if we do that one of the school speech
standard applies not the normal stress
scrutiny First Amendment test
unfortunately the schools didn't come up
with this idea on their own because
agencies of the federal government and
many state statutes put this
responsibility on schools in areas such
as bullying
the law is unsettled and it's likely to
remain so because the Supreme Court just
last week denied certiorari in a case
called Bell versus itawamba County
School District in which all 16 judges
on the Fifth Circuit sitting in Bank to
review a panel decision went further
than any other appellate court in
allowing schools to discipline a student
for off-campus speech and this was
senior also with a good disciplinary
record as is true in many of these cases
African American student who wrote and
recorded a rap song and posted up on
YouTube in which he accused two of the
coaches of the school of sexually
harassing four girls who had talked to
him about the problem and no one ever
argued in court or even asserted out
of court that this was not true
no one said including the judge the
coaches that this had never happened but
the school said this is harassment of
school personnel which the code doesn't
allow now these were gangster rap lyrics
they used the fictional conventions and
the figurative violence that is always
found in rap songs as killer Mike
indicated in a brief to the Supreme
Court urging them to grant cert and the
cert petition and they briefed on the
cert petition informs the court in case
they might not know that killer Mike
himself has that actually ever killed
anyone okay so this leads the law very
different in different parts of the
country about off-campus speech meaning
if a lot depends if you live in Texas or
Mississippi or if you live in Washington
DC or Boston but it is well known from
reading these cases are very clear from
these cases that criticisms of school
staff members are a very likely kind of
speech to get a student in trouble
schools don't like that they reach out
and they do serious punishments Taylor
Behl was sent to an alternative school
for troubled kids even though it was his
first offense and similar things have
happened to students who have posted
so-called satirical adolescent humor
fake MySpace pages about their school
principals making fun of school
administrators complaining about a main
staff member or bad teachers like I hate
miss Phelps but freedom of speech exists
to protect dissidents including those
who criticize authorities and power that
is a core principle of democracy and one
that should be honored in our school
systems the states reach into the
child's home in these cases also creates
an express conflict
between what educators think and
parental liberty interests and deciding
how to raise their children and what
it's acceptable for their children to
say and do and post from the home
parents often punish the students in
these cases not just the off-campus
speech cases but the on-campus speech
cases if their speech was rude or crude
but they sue the school to get the
coercive discipline of the state off
their child's permanent record because
that can have a profound impact on the
child's life and if I have time I'll
tell you one more story thank you it's a
great story my last example this was an
on-campus inquisition into a private
online conversation between two middle
school students from their homes in
rural Minnesota Minnesota the
conversation had something to do with
sex we never learned its actual content
it was conducted on the internet off
school grounds and outside school hours
when school officials learned about it
from the family of the boy who initiated
the conversation they went after the
girl who responded to his invitation to
talk about sex and they pulled her out
of class and opened her laptop and
demanded her IDs and passwords for all
her accounts they didn't call her mother
they interrogated her with the police
present they opened all her accounts she
was sobbing and they found a Facebook
sex quiz which she said I thought it was
fun and funny and they condemned her for
doing this online quiz as well as for
her personal correspondence was a
warrantless search without any grounds
at all and when the mother filed a
lawsuit saying they had violated her
daughter's first and Fourth Amendment
rights even though they had not actually
punished her I became clear where the
judge was going
case settled for $70,000 we've learned
since this episode from the Supreme
Court that personal computers and phones
pulled everything that is in a person's
mind that was not as clear at the time
but it is clear now these intrusions
into off-campus expression that the
First Amendment protects teach young
people the opposite lesson of the lesson
justice Jackson in Barnett said we
should be teaching they teach students
to dismiss as meaningless the rights we
tell them they have they teach young
people that there's no place to hide
from an authoritarian government these
officials are immune from criticism
undermining every core principle of our
liberal democratic state and I look
forward to the responses and to the
questions professor Ross's examples from
high school were called to me for the
first time in many years that I once got
dragged into the principal's office for
as I recall talking inappropriately
during the reading of the Lord's Prayer
now given that the at that point the
school is a public school and the school
officials were involved in violating
another part of the first of it but in
retrospect it was my finest hour but it
it didn't really seem like that at the
time so our first commentator will be
Seagal bin pirat who has traveled from
Philadelphia today to be with us for
this book form and we thank her for that
dr. bin pirat received her doctorate in
political philosophy from Tel Aviv
University she was awarded two
successive tella the university
presidents post doctoral grants there in
2001 to 2004 she was a postdoctoral
research associate at the University
Center for human values at Princeton
University while in Israel she served on
a joint palestinian-israeli committee
sponsored by the Perez Peace Center
working toward educational reform
dr. bin pirat was a member of the young
scholars forum at the ravine Center for
the Study of Israel participated in the
women faculty forum at tel aviv
university and established the israeli
association for post-secondary education
for students with learning disabilities
her research focuses on citizenship
education normative aspects of
educational and social policy and social
effects of war her areas of expertise
include philosophy of education and
political philosophy her books include
citizenship under fire democratic
education in times of conflict in 2006
and tough choices structure paternalism
and the landscaped of choice both of
which appeared with Princeton University
Press dr. Ben Perez welcome to the cato
institute for your first appearance
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you John and Catherine and thank
you for the invitation for my first
appearance at Cato and for the
opportunity to discuss this important
book I've been thinking and studying
civic education for quite a while right
up until now and I'd mentioned that two
other things that inform my reading of
this book is my current work with
preparing novice teachers through Teach
for America and working with school
administrators where I try to press on
them some of the key issues that relate
to free speech in schools and and other
legal and social expectations that we
have of practitioners in in the field of
education and I'd also mentioned that
I'm serving currently as the chair of
the Committee on open expression at the
University of Pennsylvania so definitely
I'm encountering a lot of these these
matters in the college context but today
focusing on this book I'd like to
basically just raise two points one a
philosophical or principled point and
the other a more practical point so the
first one the book exposes the patchy
and sometimes contradicting foundations
on which we rest our expectations of
schools in the domain of educating for
democracy very broadly beyond free
speech schools are expected to reflect
and model democratic principles such as
free speech but given that they are
working with children and youth they are
also expected to control their students
behaviors in ways that would readily be
recognized as unconstitutional in other
contexts right so we have this
conflicting demand which is basically
the starting point I think for a lot of
the litigation that the book discusses
in various ways we expect schools to
operate in less than fully democratic
ways we being society or sometimes
administrators the way they see their
their jobs and sometimes our actual
legal practices such as compulsory
attendance laws right this would not be
acceptable if we talked about adults but
they are acceptable when we talk about
children if we focus for a moment on
speech solely as an expression of the
core values that one holds which of
course is just a subset of all speech
and when it comes to children and
particularly youth is probably just even
a smaller subset right so we have a lot
of what would be called worthless speech
as you turn even if we think about
speech only in the context of speech as
expressing core values schools are meant
to reflect the reality of value
pluralism in society and thus to allow
for a variety of views to be heard and
and this is not only to preserve rights
but also to sustain the school as a
microcosm of a vibrant public sphere and
that was the key message I think coming
from Tinker on the other hand if we
think about schools as training grounds
for democracy rather than as a microcosm
of democracy then we more readily accept
the need to limit redirect and even
silence speech we may reasonably expect
that [ __ ] that scores more strongly
guide and mold students including
limiting their speech rights and other
rights if we think that students are
further away from being ready to take on
their civic roles so our view of schools
as democratic microcosms on the one hand
or as training ground for democracy on
the other depends in turn on our views
and of course most importantly the
courts views of Children and Youth are
they many adults who should practice
their civic roles in as realistic a
setting as possible or conversely are
they and I quote barbarians who need to
be tamed and trained so that they can
fit into our heart woman and establish
social order this book offers a
framework for reforming current legal
approaches or or pushing them in a
certain direction
and informing practice in a way that
expands student speech rights and in
this sense it is firmly placed in the
former camp the camp that sees children
as junior citizens and schools as
reflection of the Democratic public
sphere and this is very close to the
Dewey and view which has a long history
of course in American public schools and
it's obviously a very worthy and well
established one but it is worth noting
that both in the theory and in the
practice of Education this view pretty
much is considered to have lost to the
other view right so it seems to be
peripheral to the more central vision as
we see in the court's decision and in
the examples of
that professor Ross suggested and that I
want to present an even more extreme
aversion of right now so this leads me
to my second comment this was the
theoretical one now I have a more
practical comment about the book in the
field of practice the speech rights of
students are violated more often than is
justified or if we take as seriously as
we should both the letter and the spirit
of Tinker and of this book more than is
legally justified if indeed schools have
neatly important role in training young
people to assume the mantle of
citizenship it is crucial that not only
as scholars and protectors of the law
but also as citizens we train our gaze
at the more common practices in
contemporary schools that some of us
even as the Lord's Prayer is not
regularly recited in public schools
anymore it is in some parts of the
country but but not as commonly as in
the past but still there are many newer
practices in schools that we should be
aware of and concerned about to the
extent that we care as we should about
student speech rights so many schools
today are taking a route that circumvent
the entire debate we're having today by
policing student speech to the extent
that it doesn't exist within the school
walls the discussion of student speech
rights in this important book rests on
the existence of speak of a speech act a
student speaks or holds a banner a
practitioner responds maybe suspending
them and then the court needs to decide
whether the effect whether in fact the
speech act should have been protected
taking into account both the content of
the speech as we've seen post tinker and
the context in which the speech took
place whether within the school or
sometimes outside of school as we heard
it was clear to me as I read this
account of the development of the courts
view of student speech rights that the
more expensive inter
tation which I to view as essential to
sustaining democratic values principles
and practices in American society cannot
easily be realized in today's education
policy environment most centrally I'm
concerned by the question to what extent
can the act of speech itself be
protected in schools to what extent can
you can we defend students rights to
speak independent of the content of
their speech in a growing number of
contemporary schools and I've been doing
research on this for the past two years
mostly in Philadelphia in a growing
number of schools especially those
serving low-income and minority students
students spends days weeks and months
without ever being allowed to use their
voices classroom activity is paced and
times timed with the teacher at the
center of the activity and the students
expected to follow her lead and respond
only when spoken to and only with the
response that is written in the
teacher's guide in the rare cases in
which discussion is permitted it is
focused on a question of limited breadth
and usually there is a timer on the
teachers power point and it is set most
commonly to forty-five seconds it goes
up to three minutes and you get a very
limited question such as how would you
solve this equation or sometimes what
would you that's that's my favorite
example what would you do if you were
Malcolm X and you get two minutes to
discuss with your friends it's a guided
discussion and then think it's over and
we are back to listening to the teacher
I've seen also numerous cases of
compelled speech in these contexts
particularly when students are used when
sorry teachers are using calls or chance
to draw the students attention and to
make sure that they are focusing so for
example the teacher would call smart and
all the students would have to respond
scholars and or whatever it might be
right First Amendment
so you would get some kind of call and
response if you don't participate in the
response even if you were sitting
quietly not being disruptive listening
to the teacher but you didn't respond to
the chant you will be reprimanded
usually with detention and after four
times with suspension outside these
compelled speech and outside the debates
that I just described to you the rest of
the school day is silent
including the hallways and most notably
and depressingly for me the lunchroom
speaking to the person next to you at
lunch is a privilege that has to be
earned and weeks can pass in which whole
schools kindergarten to 12th grade are
required to have silent lunches student
March the hallways single-file with one
hand covering their mouth so that they
remember not to speak the use of one's
voice including whispering laughing and
again quite depressing Lee sighing this
is considered to be a violation of
school behavior code and it's met with
an automatic punitive response the
reasoning behind this practice is the
reasonable belief that students must
attain a strong level of academic
performance in order to succeed in life
in different domains including as
citizens and also the less reasonable
belief that this can only be achieved if
they are monitored and limited to these
extreme extents and there is one
sentence in the book I want to read to
you that shows the courts aligning with
this view judges this is in relation to
the Moores case the bond seats for Jesus
case judges have read the courts anxiety
post Moore's about violence and subpar
learning environments to justify
restricting civil liberties where
schools are failing right so where we
have lower performing schools we
a stronger reasoning or supposed
justification to limit students free
speech rights and other rights the
village tyrant is a powerful metaphor
for those who subvert undermine or
silenced student speech rights and as we
sees throughout this book their tyranny
is expressed in their efforts to
suppress speech most notably
by defining various speech acts as
unacceptable or on the other hand useful
speech as required right within the
context of a school I would encourage
those of us who care about student
speech rights to consider also those
increasingly common practices which may
be harder to address within our current
legal framework but which nonetheless
stand in the way of a democratic
education for citizenship and would
clearly not be supported by a learning
liberty framework that we just heard
about from Professor Ross to be clear I
wholeheartedly agree that basic academic
skills and equal educational opportunity
are essential to a functioning democracy
for reasons that I'm not elaborate here
it is vital though that we recognize
that like reading or math citizenship
too is learned by doing and it skills
will not evolve as a side effect of
maturity or of academic attainment
practicing the skills of being a citizen
is essential for a democrat amok recei
which aims to sustain a vibrant public
sphere informed by key democratic
principles creating and sustaining
school environments that support this
gradual intentional development of these
skills requires focused on the
protection of democratic school
environment environments in which
student free speech and other basic
rights are properly recognized and
celebrated thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much
you know the Quito Institute really
depends on the first amendment a lot of
ways it's part of our strategy right
from the beginning it was always part of
Cato's kind of outsider status we were
advocating ideas from an 85 or 95 and so
on
that really hadn't gained traction in
some ways so we wanted to get people who
were the dominant views to come here and
debate us so the first amendment was
essential to our idea of how we became
part of the national conversation we
always want make sure that things we had
that the Kato position was enunciated
this was defended and today professor
Ross I thought of it setting up this
panel would be part of the Kato position
or maybe all the Kato advocates for our
the libertarian position on this but we
also do education here and this has an
education Nexus so I thought to include
my colleague neal mccluskey who does
education here at Cato Neal is in fact
the director of the Cato Center for
Educational Freedom prior to arriving at
Cato he served in the US Army taught
high school English and maybe he'll have
some stories from that time for us and
was a friend of freelance reporter
covering municipal government and
education in suburban New Jersey more
before becoming the director of the
center he was policy analyst at the
center for education reform he's the
author of feds in the classroom how big
government corrupts cripples and
compromises American education and his
writings have appeared in all the
leading publications he's been on c-span
before on CNN Fox and numerous radio
programs he holds an undergraduate
degree from Georgetown where he double
majored in government and English as a
master's degree in political science
from Rutgers University and a PhD in
public policy from George Mason welcome
man
thank you all very much and especially
professor Ross thank you for writing
this book I think you know doing
education policy all the time that
threats to basic rights in public
schools is not a subject that gets
nearly enough attention all sorts of
sort of questions about what we teach
how we teach it how kids interact those
have all sort of been pushed aside with
an obsession over test scores everything
is what is the test scores what's the
test scores by the way what are the test
scores and these are topics that we
absolutely need to talk about now I
think there may be some collusion
between people who run schools and the
public transportation system in DC
trying to keep people away from today's
event by closing down conveniently the
metro but we'll see within the book I
especially appreciate the discussion of
dangerous federal overreach I've done
some work on the federal role in
education but the especially the
anti-bullying 2010 Dear Colleague letter
and somebody in the audience over there
actually asked me about this before the
event so I I hope you can talk about
Dear Colleague letters but it was
particularly striking that you say it
only mentioned the First Amendment in a
footnote and only once and it seems that
that probably ought to come up a little
more often when we're giving directions
for schools about how you deal with
people's speech the First Amendment
shouldn't get one mentioned in a
footnote I do though have one
particularly huge objection to something
you wrote in the book which is on page
273 and I want to quote it exactly quote
conservative groups including the Cato
Institute dot-dot-dot unquote you in
your book you talk about fighting words
which is the kind of thing speech that's
not protected by the First Amendment
Cato's libertarian not conservative and
I think that that falls under fighting
words
we're not going to call the police in
this case but but it's an important
distinction
met any of you wonderful people fight
averted I think it's absolutely right
that public school so as government
entities are often way too inclined to
curb basic expression rights I think
that is very clear in this book if
you're not clear on that already read
the book you will be but we also I think
have to be clear about two things and
these these are concerns I have about
the book one public schools are often as
I think professor ben-tor 'litham talked
about they're not actually often thought
of as sort of training places for us to
work at our differences or as you say
places I thought that's a great quote
learning liberty by living it I think
that people tend to not look at schools
that way this is why this topic I think
doesn't come up that much and second it
concerns me the use of the term
democracy and it's not just in your book
it's throughout any education fight or
any education discussion or debate and
I'll get into a little bit more about
why I think the use of the term is
problematic for the first point though I
think that if you even read the major
advocates of public schooling sort of
historically they weren't all that
interested in again learning liberty by
living it as something that the schools
were primarily about they were more
about shaping people I think from above
so Benjamin Rush is a pretty well-known
founding father big in Philadelphia big
in Pennsylvania he was really an early
advocate of widespread public schooling
and he said he should create a public
schooling system that would quote render
the mass of the people more homogeneous
and thereby fit them more easily for
uniform and peaceable government and he
talked about teaching sort of
inculcating common morals so it wasn't
really about people sort of themselves
getting together talking about their
differences it was more will take sort
of an elite notion of what a proper
citizen is make people sort of identical
and there we won't have problems when
they're older and they're able to have
liberty horse man often called the
father of the public schools or the
common schools of godfather in the
common schools no matter what name you
give him he was probably the leading
advocate for for public schooling in the
1830s 1840s
and he talked about public schooling not
really again about bringing in diverse
people to work out their differences and
to talk about what made them difference
but making them sort of similar sort of
you know people who held the same sort
of elite views that he did he talked
about defusing general intelligence to
but it was really about inculcating
common morality and it was a common
morality that I think he hoped was held
by people a lot like him if you go will
go just to the the Progressive Era so
the turn of the 20th century just as one
more example Elwood Cubberley
was a very well known public schooling
thinker an advocate and again a lot he
and a lot of people who were like him
didn't necessarily see the schools as a
place where you learn liberty in fact he
said quote we should give up the
exceedingly democratic idea that all are
equal and that our society is devoid of
classes the employee tends to remain an
employee the wage earner tends to remain
a wage earner and this was the period of
using IQ test d'etat decide well your
future is in a factory and maybe for a
small percent your future is in college
and this again so wasn't really oriented
toward our public schools are where we
learned to be citizens who have equal
rights with everyone else and we work
out our differences ourselves certainly
some public school advocates did want
that and we and professor Ben port
already talked about John Dewey he was
much more in this mold of we have
schools where kids would come together
from different backgrounds they'd work
on sort of project together and they
would learn to live together and it's
sort of a different view than this kind
of top-down notion I think was more a
driver of public schooling this idea
that we should sort of shape people in a
way to be kind of uniform and again the
discussion it seems to me of even those
goals today has been you know fifth or
six or seven three nine hundredth
priority next to test scores test scores
test scores that I think is what in many
cases we have reduced education to being
then just talk a little bit about the
term democracy and this comes up a lot
for me and I think it's very important
how we use it
and it's often sort of used
interchangeably to mean a lot of things
that can mean representative government
to some people can be kind of a leveling
of people it can people can say it as
synonymous with individual liberty
sometimes for people it means majority
rule often it means just from some way
public control or public rule in this
latter notion I think kind of drives a
common belief when we get beyond the
test doors that public schools should
basically respond to whatever the
community however you define that
community once usually it's whoever is
being represented by that school board
and that leads to a fundamental clash
about what the schools do the individual
rights versus the community values a lot
of this you know sociologists know
people say education is about social
reproduction so the community says this
is how we shape students to be part of
our community our society and that means
they have to share our norms and values
and not do things that concern us I
think you can see that most clearly and
sort of Morse be Frederick it may be
because nobody ever forgets bong hits
for Jesus so you remember that case
there's another you go back to colonial
era another law no one's ever heard of
it I think they never forget after I
tell them they say the first law for
public schools was called the old
deluder Satan act so if you can get
Jesus or Satan in the name of law or in
a court case people remember it in any
event I think ultimately there's a
fundamental problem especially if we
talk about democratic control this idea
that we should have some sort of public
control it's inherently conflictual the
conflicts cannot be escaped and now I'm
gonna do sort of a shameless plug well
not really that shameless but we run
something called the public schooling
battle map and I think it's about to go
up behind me I never rely on my own
ability to operate anything there we go
so the public schooling battle map the
reason it's here is is it it's supposed
to sort of illustrate to people how many
sort of conflicts we have in public
schools there this doesn't include about
well how do you teach multiplication or
you know what's the right day to start
the school year or what hour do we start
the school day this is about Val
use an identity based conflicts that we
have in public schools and the reason it
tends to be inherently conflictual is
that you have diverse people use their
ideological a diverse linguistically
diverse ethnically diverse religiously
diverse but they are all ultimately
supporting one system and we're trying
to get the system to to to treat them or
to educate them all but one system can't
teach everything that everybody wants
and so you can see this it can be
deceptive just to look at it so they're
actually way more conflicts than you see
here because a lot of those little pins
bury other pins but if you were to pull
out you'd also it would look less
intense and you think that a lot of
places where nobody lives for instances
no no markers there but there there a
lot of places where there are people if
you don't see one of these and as you
talked about in the book you know what
makes it to towards and often what makes
it into the media it's not every
conflict that we have probably it's a
tip of the iceberg so this may just be
the tip of the iceberg but the point
here is to illustrate that we're
constantly having conflicts over all
sorts of issues and I think the best
illustration may be is if you think of
library books and on page 101 a
professor Ross's book she notes that
schools can choose to buy any book they
want or not buy any book they want for
whatever reason but if you get into the
removal of a book you say that a parent
says well I don't think that this book
is appropriate in the middle school
library or I don't think this should be
on my child's reading list that becomes
a constitutional issue of is this
government censorship if you remove it
we concede the problems should the
government be able to favor speech for
whatever reason it wants so it deems
this book is worthy of having kids read
it or putting it library this book over
here this speech over here is not worthy
of being in the library and that is
inherently conflictual and so we have on
the map just to illustrate the
incredible power of the map and
user-friendliness
there we go is these are all the book
banning reading material conflicts we
have again probably tip of the iceberg
but they're about 220 of these and this
is only this is collected
maybe 10 years we started in 2005 some
of them reached farther back but it's
just things that I we see in the news
and we pull out here but that's
inherently conflictual 220 of these is
it unjust ultimately you compel support
for those who would not choose to pay
for say Robert Cormier it's the
chocolate war you may not have read it
but that's one of the most challenged
books or what about people say I don't
think I should pay for or I don't think
my children should have to read The
Adventures of Huckleberry Finn well how
do you bounce it with the people say yes
these are very valuable books to read
government one way or another it's
making the decision what to read or what
not to read we can also talk about human
origins everybody knows creation versus
evolution but inherently there is a
problem that leads to inequality so if
you teach evolution alone automatically
creationists feel like they're
second-class citizens and you might even
say it's religious discrimination that
they can't have their viewpoint and
they're also but you add creationism and
you're injecting religion which is
certainly something that we don't want
government to do so you can't treat all
these people equally also I think a
couple more just small critiques well
it's crucially important to protect
speech and and i think professor ben
porous talked about this a little so I
won't go into it too much but I think
there is a good argument especially for
teachers people you know in the
classroom every day for saying you've
got to have a lot of discipline even if
it means peoples speech goes away
because it can be very difficult to
teach where you need to teach to run a
classroom if you don't have that and
even if someone is saying something that
is perfectly legitimate viewpoint you
can't have your 45 minutes devolve into
a debate about something when you need
to cover other material both for
educational purposes and of course for
testing purposes you've always got to
cover other material and then finally I
think there's something important about
shared norms and beliefs I think
research by James Coleman and others
have shown that private schools
especially religious schools may in fact
outperform public schools because
ultimately everyone who goes to that
school accepts the school's norms and
values and that creates sort of cohesion
you don't have to have as we see in
public schools sort of rule by law and
right
elation and often a muddling through as
you illustrate very well in the book
we're not really sure what to do how do
we decide on what policy to have or how
to treat this student when we know it'll
make some people in the community angry
and others won't like what I do if I
don't punish the students in private
schooling everybody you agree basically
what the handbook says and that enables
the school to run much more coherently
and cohesively and it maybe leads to
better academic outcomes I don't want to
say that I think that this is slam dunk
research but there is some research to
show this and I think that given the
inherent conflict of publics going the
only way to truly treat people equally
and protect them from government
incursions on their rights speech rights
religious rights etc is educational
freedom ultimately attach money to
students not to specific schools and
give educators freedom to start the kind
of schools they want with the policies
they want with the curriculum they want
and let those people freely interact and
so somebody who wants maximum expression
rights in the school can choose a school
like that somebody who says no I want
sort of the no excuses tough discipline
you know maybe not even speaking in the
cafeteria kind of atmosphere they can
choose that as well and then if you're
not happy if you say I chose a school
that doesn't have a strict anti-bullying
policy because I want maximum freedom
but my child is getting bullied to the
point I can't tolerate it you can also
leave that school and that's just you
point out in the book that's a problem
with public schools is in a way you're a
captive audience this gives you an
ability to escape and you could choose
schools for any other number of reasons
not just these policies so in that sort
of case government wouldn't decide on
speech rights or religious rights or
anything else
parents would make those decisions and
it could even as I said go elsewhere if
they're unhappy so I think it's
absolutely important crucial to
understand the threats to freedom of
speech and other freedoms and how to
minimize them in public schools I think
this book does an absolutely terrific
job of talking about those issues diving
into them talking about how to resolve
them I especially like your chart which
I'm going to
in my office for anyone a cup says stuff
I don't like but I think it's even more
important ultimately to move to a system
it's those kinds of threats can be
escaped by the people that the education
systems supposed to serve thank you
[Applause]
Neil's comment about the distinction
between conservatives and libertarians
reminded me of my old friend Walter
burns book freedom virtue in the First
Amendment which goes back to the 1950s
you might read it you will not get the
sense that it is a libertarian book it
is indeed a very different kind of
approach the first amendment that you
can call conservative that said I think
it might be worth emphasizing at this
moment that most of the conservatives
liberals are almost all the
conservatives liberals and indeed
libertarians that I know think New York
Times versus Sullivan was rightly
decided which is to say that they don't
believe that public figures should have
heightened protection against libel and
they're most of them on all three camps
I think are frankly appalled to hear
successful politicians suggest otherwise
and on that note we shall go to our
questions and answers please wait to
raise your hand please wait to be called
upon wait for the microphone so we can
project this out through the world and
you know announce your name and
affiliation unless you think you have
reasons to want to remain anonymous
which I don't think anyone really does
and above all please keep your comments
in the form of a question
if possible this gentleman here thank
you my name is Brett Hines and I'm with
American University when I went to high
school I went to a private Catholic High
School
so the debates around free speech there
don't quite match the same but I was
wondering if a personal experience that
I've had with censorship by
administration how that would play out
in public schools I was the editor of
the school newspapers op-ed section and
I was planning on publishing a editorial
opposing the administration's position
that had tacitly taken on
sexuality and they demanded that they
review the article before publishing it
and ultimately they took several months
with the review until I left the school
coincidentally but I suppose my question
is that when it comes to school
sponsored speech how does the
administration have the ability to
review what students want to say in
something like a school newspaper in a
public school absolutely in a public
school they would have they can say
we're reviewing everything before it
comes out they can censor it by
eliminating the article altogether by
forcing you to rewrite it by taking
parts out and in fact the case that
created this doctrine was about a school
newspaper that wanted to run actual news
stories not opinion pieces about teenage
pregnancy in the school and about the
impact of divorce on students and the
principle essentially got rid of two
whole pages of the newspaper because he
wanted to get rid of those two articles
at the last minute and the court said
that was okay but it went further it
didn't limit its holding to school
newspapers so while yours was labeled an
opinion piece they might say that either
this was not a topic that was
appropriate for a school sponsored
newspaper or that the viewpoint was so
provocative within the community that
they never you know I said earlier they
can't really say they're going to censor
it because it's controversial but that
it might be too difficult for some of
the younger students to handle they
would find some pedagogical reason what
where schools go wrong is that they've
gotten sort of lazy they often don't
even bother to come up with a reason
they just say can't publish it then
they'll lose but if they try it can
usually come up with something that's
the sad news I'm actually going at the
end of this week to talk to the annual
meeting of the Columbia scholastic
journalism Association which is the
meeting of all of the high school
students who run student publications
and their advisors so I'll probably have
some more stories after that meeting the
woman in the center in the back row so
rude being a moderator you know their
names hi I'm Sarah I'm also from
American University my question for you
guys is well this does seem to be a
general problem across the United States
do you think it should be addressed
nationally or in individual communities
that's a terrific question
as Neil indicated local control is a
very important part of our educational
system elected school boards local
superintendents and as far as I'm able
to grasp the newly crafted law that
replaced No Child Left they had behind
the federal government is stepping back
from giving the kind of guidance they've
been giving for the last ten years but
the constitutional law is federal law so
we really have to have an interplay
between an understanding of First
Amendment law interpreted by federal
courts and what communities do on the
ground and and one of the
recommendations I make in my book is
that just because the First Amendment
allows schools to engage in certain
kinds of censorship or in to place
certain inhibitions on students speech
doesn't mean that school districts have
to use those powers so one thing that
people who believe in a more a model of
Education that emphasizes learning how
to be citizens in an active way might do
is run for school board or go and tell
the school board we would like to be a
community in which the school doesn't
limit students speech that isn't
disruptive
even though you have the power to do
that we'd like to send a different
message in this environment usually the
people who talk up about
speech in the local community or those
who would like more censorship rather
than less until there's an incident and
once there's a censorship incident quite
understandably principals and school
boards tend to dig in their heels rather
than to reconsider their policies so I
suggest this is a good conversation to
have before a play has been cancelled or
some other issue has arisen other
questions down here to the right we'll
get both of these gentlemen hi Michael
Enders Washington DC wondering if any of
the courts have considered the
possibility that educators would be
doing well to solicit provocative speech
rather than just allow it ah I love that
idea but I've never seen a court say it
and I don't know have you ever seen a
principal saying well I've seen I've
seen some administrators who profess to
encourage who encourage controversial
speech there is actually a very
interesting study that was published in
a book called controversy in the
classroom Hess and MacAvoy are the two
authors and they actually show they're a
set of cases in which classroom teachers
are using controversial topics and
controversial opinions as pedagogical
vehicles for developing civic capacity
or for sometimes the writing learning
how to write or for speech and debate
purposes but in the regular classroom
not at the club right and basically they
show that generally speaking I mean this
is a very large study that they did over
five years with thousands of students
that they later also followed up with
after they graduated to see the extent
in which the
the extent to which they they remain
active citizens right to the extent to
which they vote or participate in other
ways and they do show that when you
encourage and also model controversial
speech in the classroom for example when
you live in a community where most
people for example are very strong
advocates of the Second Amendment and
you come in even if it's not your view
as a teacher right but you come in and
you say here is why we should have very
strict gun control regulations or the
opposite right then basically your
capacity to encourage students to
develop critical thinking skills and
respectful debate skills and all of
these other capacities that allow you to
be a good active efficacious citizens
are really strengthened by this right so
you do see it in practice from teachers
and administrators I won't say that this
is the mainstream yeah I would just add
that I think that schools and educators
tend to avoid controversial issues quite
apart from the First Amendment question
because often the school sometimes the
school has a again diverse community
that it's working with and they're just
trying to avoid conflicts that might
give them a hard time
and there was worked by to political
science Berkman and flood sir
and it came out a few years ago now that
they've done subsequent work but that
surveyed biology teachers and they found
that about 60 some percent of biology
teachers soft-pedal evolution or don't
teach it at all mainly because they're
trying or they think mainly because
they're just trying to avoid getting
anybody angry so a lot of avoiding
controversy isn't even about First
Amendment it's makes your life easier
not to aggravate people well teachers
can also lose their jobs if parents get
angry enough in their yeah and even even
if they have tenure and if they stray
from the viewpoint in the curriculum
that the School Board has true
they can get in a lot of trouble David's
Olson
some years ago I worked for the Michigan
State Legislature and I worked on a bill
to protect the rights of public schools
school students in publishing newspapers
there are plenty of sources of rights
for students besides the US Constitution
each state has its own Constitution and
each state can pass statewide laws so
I'd like to know has that happened have
state courts relied on state
constitutions to protect students rights
have states passed statutes protecting
students rights to free speech terrific
question
yes a number of states have enacted
higher protections for student speech
rights than are currently found in the
federal doctrine from the courts
California basically says the material
disruption standard applies to every
kind of student speech in K through 12
regardless of the Supreme Court
precedence and they also a few years ago
passed a law protecting the advisors to
high school publications going back to
your question about your op-ed piece if
an advisor in California fights to
protect the rights of the student
journalists the statute says they can't
be discharged for that and there are a
number of organizations that are
actively working to try to get more
states to pass more protective laws for
student journalists a number of states
came close to doing it but experienced
vetoes from governor's one case involved
students in a suburb of Chicago at a
very good high school with an
award-winning newspaper who discovered
that there the staff of the school
district had gone on junkets and they
dug out the travel receipts and showed
they stayed you know more days in the
hotel than the meeting went on and
things like that and they weren't
allowed to publish
in the school newspaper but the Chicago
Tribune found it met all of the
standards for journalists investigations
and published it and after that the
Illinois legislature passed a student
rights statute to cover student
journalists and the governor vetoed it
pretty shameful hmm
but but they're definitely that is
another place going back to thee is this
a local or a national problem it's both
gentlemen right here
Thank You Lars
Leibler asking this question in my
capacity as a high school basketball
coach at a public school in Fairfax
County I'm wondering whether your
scholarship touches on this issue I've
been following a case that I think is
progressing now there's a football coach
in the state of Washington who over the
course of his career head at the end of
games going to the center of the field
and prayed by himself which apparently
didn't raise a problem some of the kids
on the team then said coach what are you
doing while I'm praying is it can we
join you of course it's a free country
which people whenever they say that
that's always wrong so as more and more
people joined him for the prayer he then
was suspended and I think that case is
ongoing I'm wondering whether any of
your scholarship and research sort of
touches on that issue it seems like it
only became a problem when the students
came voluntarily to pray with him yes
the last chapter of my book focuses in
in large part on religious expression by
students and one of the problems in this
area is that next to the the doctrine
governing students speech which many
judges sort of throw up their hands and
say this is just too confusing for me I
don't know how to use it which you know
they do preside over antitrust in other
very difficult cases but trying to make
it clearer
next to that the condition of the
Establishment Clause is an enormous
disarray because the Supreme Court has
basically not relied on a certain old
set of doctrine and hasn't really
replaced it with anything else so
individual justices have their own
approaches but the lower courts don't
have much guidance and so teachers and
principals are confused about what
amounts to an Establishment Clause
violation how does this relate to free
speech for students they too often think
that if students express religious views
like praying over the sandwich I brought
from home not even trying to get other
students to join in that the school will
be accused of an Establishment Clause
violation for allowing this to take
place that is clearly not true the
Supreme Court has repeatedly said that
students have the right to pray in
school again as long as they're not
disrupting class and to express through
speech their religious viewpoints to
each other the problem is when you have
a teacher encouraging people then we
have a question about is participation
really voluntary so the law is pretty
clear this should be from the students
themselves they're very different if a
group of students say you know we've
noticed the coach has been praying in
the middle of the field and we'd like to
do that too do they do it separately do
they join the coach when the coach says
team members whose lives I'm pretty much
in charge of a lot of the time and I'm
very important authority figure to you
you want to join me I think that's a
closer question and certainly if he said
we are going to do this as a team that's
forbidden
gentlemen in the center and we'll have a
couple more and have to wrap up
um Jacob marks American University I
have kind of quick scenario question for
you if a teacher is hospitalized due to
an incident at a high school and is
assaulted in the process and that's how
she ends up in the hospital and she
posts on Facebook that she ends up in
the hospital and gets fired because of
it is that violating her First Amendment
right I'm sorry
the teacher sorry I wasn't really clear
the teacher was assaulted in an incident
school and was hospitalized because of
it well in the hospital she was she
posts on a social media site that she
was in the hospital can she be fired for
that it depends part the law will be
different depending where she lives
because the appellate courts are not
entirely in agreement but there are
except there are some limits to what
public employees including teachers can
say about their work and so a lot would
depend on whether this was considered a
matter of public concern or not and
hypothetically you know if she were
let's say attacked by a student or by
the school principal that probably to me
would seem like a matter of public
concern but if it was something else
then she probably could be but it's very
hard to say without knowing both more
and where this took place gentlemen
right here we have to be our last
question
dr. McCluskey to your point isn't this
whole issue really more not about free
expression but but property rights isn't
public property the original sin in this
whole debate where if you you know if
you did not public property public
school the government wouldn't be in the
position to be an arbiter of speech well
I've never put it that way and I'm not
an expert on property law or anything
like that
I do think that that is certainly
a root problem if the government weren't
providing the schools then most of these
issues would go away now there are a lot
of arguments for why government provide
schools that you could certainly have I
think what's important is we do need to
look I think somewhat below the
conflicts themselves and say well what
may be causing us to have all these
conflicts the reality is I hope we move
to school choice we are moving to school
choice to some extent and that needs
means private schools because even
charter schools understand our public
schools so they're still bound by all
this but and well we've made great
progress we're nowhere near most people
going to private schools so these are
very real issues that are going to pie
have to be dealt with until we can reach
the idea where everybody is going what I
think is ideal to a private school
because then you and the educators
essentially agree on what the rules are
going to be and that's the best way to
balance lots of competing goods one
where people just put different values
on different things but also where some
things can't coexist together so you
can't have a school that's both
non-religious and that teachers say
religious doctrine which a lot of people
want but in terms of whether or not it's
a public property issue I at least
haven't I've never framed it that way
when Russell Ross that I met in January
when she was on a panel here one point
she said to me you know outside the
First Amendment I disagree with a lot of
things Cato advocates now of course I
was perplexed because having all the
answers I'm always kind of perplexed
when people disagree with me but there's
a point here that's important we don't
disagree about the First Amendment the
importance of the First Amendment
despite the fact that we are group
disagreed about many policy issues and
in fact at a time I think that's an
important thing to remember in a context
like this at a time when there's lots of
polarization lots of partisanship and
lots of seemingly intractable conflicts
it's important that people across
parties and across ideologies remain
committed and unified to a strong First
Amendment protections and I think this
book lessons and censorships how schools
the courts subverts citizens First
Amendment rights it's important
contribution to building that kind of
unity and to making us appreciate the
importance of the First Amendment I'd
like to thank professor Ross for coming
today professor Ben paratha for coming
down on a digitally difficult day to be
with us here and my colleague neal
mccluskey
for appearing on the panel most of all
on a rough day oh you must really care
about the First Amendment to come out
today and I appreciate each one of you
coming let's go have lunch and talk more
about this the lunch will be held on the
second level of the jaw at the George M
Yeager Conference Center which is up the
spiral staircase in the front of the
building our restrooms on the second
floor on your way to lunch look for the
yellow wall and you can purchase your
own copy of lessons and censorship up
there thanks very much
[Applause]
you jump